So let's finish this clustering process. So
what were you thinking of doing next?
>> Well, D and F and B and G, we both
thought were pretty close. So let's just do D and F.
>> Well, D and F doesn't matter much
anymore because they're already in the same cluster.
>> Oh, that's a good point. That's a good point.
>> So what is their inter cluster distance?
>> It's zero.
>> Yes.
>> because they're in the same cluster.
That's a fun point you make there, Michael.
>> Sure.
>> How about B and G then? I like B and G. And what do we do next?
>> Well, we have two, two nice clusters. So, actually
if we were to merge the next cluster. We would
end up with, I guess b and d together. Doesn't
really matter because it's going to merge the last two clusters together.
>> Yeah. So, in particular what I was what I was
getting at is we don't do any emerging next because now this
repeat loop is done. So that's, this is what we end
up with assuming that we had started off setting K equals two.
>> Um-hm.
>> Then, then we're done at this point.
We have what looks like a backwards R and
a funny looking, actually they look like Hebrew letters to
me but that's probably not a universal perspective. So
just one other thing to point out quickly. So we
can represent the series of merges that we did
using a structure that's kind of like this. We merged
a and b first, and then we merged c and d. And then we merged, I think d and e?
>> Yeah.
>> Or the c, d, and e. And then we merged
e and f. And then we merged g and the, and the ab cluster. And
then that left us with the two clusters. So, this, in some sense it, we've
captured the same information about what's connected
with what. But this is kind of a
nice way of representing it, because it actually
gives us a hierarchical structure. A tree structure.
>> A kind of hierarchical agglomerative structure.
>> And there's lots of applications where it's actually useful to have
that, that extra bit of information. because we can now very easily,
look at remember, in the beginning you
said that you could see three clusters? Well
you can see if you just cut this tree structure here, we get, we get the
three. Oh. Not quite. We almost get the
three clusters that you wanted. Here it looks
like f is separated from the others. It
depends which, which distances we thought were closer.
>> And also if you combine those two clusters again, the last two
clusters, then basically you, you have a true tree with a single root.
>> That's right. And, and that's kind of, that summarizes
all the different cluster structures that you
can get out of single link clustering.
>> Hm, I like that. So I have a question, Michael.
>> Shoot.
>> Well I have two questions. The first question
is do you know the difference between further and farther?
>> I do, though. I sometimes use them interchangeably.
>> Yeah, it turns out interestingly enough that that definitions
are further and farther switch every 100 years or so
>> Hm
>> And unfortunately I was
born in a time period where they're switching meanings again
and so it drives me nuts. But in any case
for our listeners, further farther means physical distance, and further
means metaphysical or metaphorical distance. So one lives farther down the
road, but goes further into debt. And you should almost
never confuse the two, the people currently are using further
as if it means farther. So I have a question
here for you, which is you define the inter cluster distance
as the distance between the closest two points in the two clusters
>> Yep, that's what it says right here.
>> Yeah, as if that were an immutable fact of the
algorithm. Is it, or could we do something else? What would
happen if we picked average distance or distance between the farthest
two points as opposed to furthest two points or some other measure?
>> [LAUGH]
Well, we don't know if this is physicaly distance
or metaphotical distance, right? Or metaphysical distance, it's just d.
>> That's true.
>> So it's like, we'll call it forthest, with an o.
>> [LAUGH] Please don't.
>> The forthest point. Yes good. And
average is another one. That's true. Yeah, these
are different things you could define. I,
my recollection of this is, they're no longer
single link clustering. Single link clustering is
defined to be closest. But you also have
other things like average link clustering, which
I think is the one with the average.
And then there's maybe max link clustering. I forget
exactly what it's called where it does the for list.
>> I think I saw a talk once as I didn't
understand which had to do with median distances. And that somehow
you could prove interesting things because of it as opposed to
the mean, which is what I think you mean by average there.
>> Yeah. Average meaning mean. Yeah, I mean, generally,
things like median are really good if the
numbers on the distances don't matter, just their orderings.
>> Mm.
>> So, sometimes people dif, describe that as being
metric versus non-metric. Non-metric, median is usually a non-metric
statistic. Average is, is a metric statistic. It actually,
the, the details of the numbers matter a lot.
>> Okay. Well that all makes sense I guess the basic idea is
that what I was saying before that the distance was some notion of where
your domain knowledge comes in. I guess it's
also true that the, how you define intercluster
distance is also a kind of domain knowledge.
It's another parameter to the algorithm. That seem fair?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.